if there's one thing in counter-strike
that truly never changes
it's the maps nearly every map in the
game is revered they're tried and tested
two-decade-old masterpieces
all except for one
vertigo
i hate that map
i hate it because
okay
this map is a nightmare the worst map in
cs goes vertigo by far
such a bad map we don't know what the
we're doing it's unrealistic yeah
see you later but what if i told you
that vertigo was also the most important
map in cs go
here we go the feet he's gonna have no
idea
oh great it's look at this oh my god
yuri that's perfect so not fully against
them kind of throwing caution the wind
even though it's such an important
moment run boost is out
he gets the kill off it dude twisted
popped off
so smoke begins to fade he will be on
the chopping block with three players
behind it what are you doing uh can you
see him there or is that just gamble is
that just rng
what if i told you that counter
needs its worst map
vertigo is one of the oldest and most
hated maps in counter-strike created in
1999 by chris narby audi the architect
of classics like inferno and aztec
vertigo goes all the way back to cs 1.1
of course the skyscraper of 20 years ago
looks very different than it does today
and pretty much only reared its head in
casual play the reason for this is that
like most of counter-strike's early
community-sourced maps it was gimmicky
disorganized and well kind of a mess
[Music]
for years from the golden age of 1.6 to
the advent of cs go vertigo was
basically irrelevant sure it saw some
action in casual context but it didn't
really matter why because it never made
it into the tiny circle of cs maps worth
caring about you see if there's one
thing that counter-strike players hate
it's change especially changes to the
maps which instead of being replaced
have been undergoing touch-ups and
repairs for the better part of two
decades in counter-strike we have a game
that has gotten to a place that we want
wanted to be at it has improved slowly
towards this
picture
of perfection that we have in our heads
about what the game should be as the
years went on and people just kept
playing the same few maps over and over
it became obvious that while cs was an
amazing game it had one glaring problem
the map pool was getting really stale
and what's worse is that for the most
part people seemed okay with that even
valve's own official rework of vertigo
from 2012 was removed from the game in
2017 because no one played it valve
hinted at the possibility of a rework
but no one noticed because well no one
cared but a few years later valve made
them care
in january 2019 valve stuck a reworked
vertigo into wingman cs go's 2v2 vs mode
it only had one bomb site available to
start but as youtubers like three clicks
phillip pointed out who knew what the
future could bring this could be valve
experimenting with a new way of testing
a map's changes
if this is the case then once they're
happy with this site maybe they'll
switch and bombsite a will be available
for wingman for a while before the map
is completely opened up and playable in
full competitive 5v5 matchmaking
and then about two months later the
community was faced with an announcement
they had to see to believe not only was
vertigo back in matchmaking it was
replacing cash in the active duty pool
cash had been in that pool since 2014 so
this change was huge with zero notice
and minimal testing vertigo was thrown
straight into the big leagues players
were outraged the suddenness of it all
but more importantly they all agreed on
one thing vertigo was a cluster
status one instead
i got one some developed a sense of
humor about the map
yeah
how could this happen to me
i made my mistakes
honestly this map is composition ready
can't wait to see in the next major and
i'm glad castro's removed others got a
little angrier about it
why do we play this map
[Music]
so too good this trap is so bad
needless to say the community couldn't
wait to see how the map would pan out on
the game's biggest stage after all
vertigo's inclusion was both
unprecedented and unexpected the issue
of course is that it didn't always lead
to the most polished play
now fly to save the map for liquid to
keep them in this he must have all three
reloading as well but he saw the jump
taking damage and backed into a corner
nowhere to go somehow still does more
he's almost no health left at home how
could he possibly make it out
30 seconds then he walks into the fire
oh no 16-8
flying off the building walking into the
fire i don't know if there are other
elements for which you can die but he's
trying a little bit of everything that's
a rough way to go and the pros
hated vernigow
i hate that map
i hate it the worst map in cisco is
vertigo by far because
it's just like you just go a just go a
go a go a it's like you're spraying
through smokes the whole game there's
not really like any outplay or any like
any any way to other play the map just i
just go away and spam i feel like it's a
lot of a executes and then the fact that
you can hear everything like literally a
level below just does not make sense to
me at all so what exactly was so wrong
about vertigo well putting aside the
part where you can literally fall off
the side of the map and die it was
chaotic claustrophobic and extremely
one-dimensional people dislike vertigo
because it's a coin flip you have to
you have to battle a ramp and you have
to end a ramp almost you can like
continuously it's like long on dust 2 b
on inferno you have to do it or you're
just at a massive disadvantage
it also b doesn't really feel good to
take and mid doesn't have high value
either so
you're left with like very little
creativity when it comes to your
approach basically there was only one
site worth hitting and only one way to
hit it if you tried doing anything else
it was going to end in well memes
because of the lack of creativity there
aren't a lot of different things you can
do on the map right now and that means
the impact of like what i mean from that
is more from a spectator point of view
the impact of the map is a bit
lame sometimes
because
you can't see some grand b execute
you've you or like a different one or
like different looks even on inferno
there's different looks
like the b hits vertigo
there's like maybe one different a hit
even at the highest levels of play the
map felt puggy and unrefined as if it
was pigeonholing top tier competition
instead of complimenting it the map
itself is terrible but
it's a great comparison both for the
maps like they are forcing you to play a
style that you don't want to play and i
feel a lot of people don't want to play
like that you know since i phased out a
competition a bit as it started becoming
a thing one trend i noticed a lot of
teams say and i can kind of see what
they mean is that it almost felt like
you didn't have enough variety on
default like you kind of just knew
every team was going to have like three
people towards the bottom of that a ramp
and two people are going to be like
holding passive b stairs and it was kind
of these like awkward fights
how much control do they have at mid
right now okay serato i mean he's just
the one here high frag position
kind of best rifler on the team
but he's in no man's land doesn't have
cover
has the off angle and i guess that's
good enough
two head shots for him even adds a
third wow there has been no footing for
sharks when it comes out mid here's the
thing though valve knew that vertigo
needed work but they also knew that the
community was stubborn and complacent
when it came to map pool changes so the
only way they could actually improve on
the new map was to literally force it
into competitors hands and that's
exactly what they did the cs community
is annoying you can't throw it in there
and if you throw it into matchmaking
people aren't gonna pick it they're not
gonna play it they still don't even when
it's even in there to learn it they
won't do it players will not do it
unless you like force them so you have
to like that's as far as valve can go to
forcing you to try it and do new things
slowly but surely the devs kept tuning
the map making a ton of changes some
slight and some significant which of
course led to even more complaints it's
not a competitive map and they they're
changing it every few months still
because it's so broken so there's just
no time to even i said we've practiced
it a little bit and then right when
we're done practicing they go ahead and
change it again so they just need to get
rid of it but for all the players who
hated the map there were some who
actually found it refreshing uh at the
time i i liked it a lot and
i definitely
liked the fact that valve was finally
changing something up since the game has
kind of been the same game for a while
and uh i don't know i it was a different
take on like a cs map and i'd say uh
it was a lot more like aim-centric so
on paper i thought i would really like
it as the months and years wore on more
competitors didn't just embrace vertigo
they innovated on it looks like they
want to set up for this boost again
lauren
it's just a whole new look i was really
just worried about these double orbs of
art and henny being able to smash them
down range but now this just change-up
is
like you said look at this it's one man
holding a so nice and he has to be on
for a multi you like it the reason i say
that is when the kill initial kill comes
in the thieves are not going through
all that it's like oh he's up i've never
seen it like they are going to be
shell-shocked from this boost
this is not i'm not going to say map
breaking by any means once it's figured
out it's figured out but this is gnarly
stuff they've mollied this off so they
feel watch this there we go
he's gonna have no idea
whoa
look at this oh my god yuri that's
perfect this boost is nuts
so not fully against them kind of
throwing caution in the wind even though
it's such an important moment run boost
is out bayern he gets the kill off it
dude twisted pops off
is it true that even today vertigo still
has a ton of problems
yeah but it's also true that keeping it
in the map pool is crucial for the
future of counter-strike the vertigo in
my opinion is one of the best maps in
mappool right now because
because of tactic stuff tactical stuff
it's really interesting you can do a lot
of things you can rush there you can do
a lot of fakes yes it needs to stay in
the map pool without question it needs
to the only way for a bad map to become
a good map and eventually a great map is
to subject it to the kind of stress
testing that only the greatest players
on earth are capable of carrying out
whether they want to or not it's
happened before and it can happen again
the original overpass the map
was dog [ __ ] all right it was awful it
was disgusting everyone hated it it took
them years and now it's like arguably my
favorite map maybe the best in the pool
but that stuff takes time and you need
the best players in the world playing on
it or you can never make adjustments you
can never really find the flaws on the
map if the highest
most paid players most individually
skilled players are not testing it for
you and while there's no denying that
part of counter-strike's charm stems
from the fact that some of the maps are
older than the kids playing on them
change doesn't just need to be
encouraged it needs to be inevitable i
love novelty and the map where i love
like when they're when there's new
colors added in like as someone who's
played dust 2 for like 20 years i don't
mind having that in in the pool but um
and i think that's really cool and
creates its own meta game
the more the longer you have a map but
yeah
you know i don't mind it i think you
know it's the same thing that happened
with kabul defaulting on cobble got
stale and so they need to change
something so i think sometimes with maps
you realize people figure out a way to
kind of
play a default one style and it gets
kind of bland and then you're like okay
well this is lame the reality is that
whether the community likes it or not
vertigo has changed csgo for the better
not only has the map itself improved
it's paved the way for even more radical
injections into the competitive rotation
ancient valve's very own in-house take
on aztec had yet to be put through the
ringer when replaced train in the active
duty pool back in may but as soon as it
came out competitors flocked to it
and what's more they actually had tons
of fun on the map
i thought you were holding it
he's up b ramp all the way
man what the silence off is this
totally unrelated he could have enough
ah
the silence off baby going to work so
are you free to not like vertigo
absolutely but maybe instead of
complaining about how awful and
unfixable it is show it some respect
because whether or not this silly
skyscraper is actually structurally
sound it has done and will continue to
do wonders for the future of cs go
yes hello what do you want cat
are you coming in now
she's so terrified she hates the filming
stuff
oh she's going back she's not interested
she's like she like came to the door and
looked in and saw all this and just like
like the like the
grandpa simpson meme
i wonder what it is
she she hates any kind of change of any
sort
if
yes much like a cs player my cat hates
change and when the green screen gets
folded up and a chair and the chair
comes in here that's not usually here
like a chair from the the dinner table
she's like oh this is bad i'm out no no
no thank you also the blinds are drawn
right now and the primary reason she
likes this room is looking out the
window